bercée dans le film armageddon un
astéroïde géant menace la terre une
équipe d'astronautes et chargé de
désintégrer avant qu'il n'entre en
collision avec la planète
un scénario spectaculaire mais très
risquée des débris pourrait causer
autant de dommage que le projectile en
entier voici plutôt le plan de match sur
lequel la nasa et l'agencé spatiale
européenne planche actuellement utilisé
une toute petite sonde pour protéger la
da contre un astéroïde menaçant en le
déviant de sa course premiers tests
prévus 2022 pas quand on regarde en
termes de probabilités les probabilités
sont très très faible mais elles sont
pas nuls et on a vu que ça a causé
vraiment de la disparition des espèces
on pense à celui d'il ya environ 65
millions d'années qui a causé vraiment
la disparition des dinosaures
c'est la chute de mes terres d'à peine
15 mai au nord de la russie en 2013 qui
a accéléré le développement de nouvelles
stratégies pour protéger la terre
plusieurs grands télescopes suivent déjà
à la trace près de 20000 astéroïde qui
circulent en périphérie du système
solaire si l'un d'entre eux semble
menaçant les experts doivent d'abord
réussir et évaluer sa trajectoire alors
ça c'est pas évident à faire et puis ça
ça prend beaucoup de temps mais il faut
le faire rapidement parce qu'une fois
qu'on qu'on sait où ils sont mais là on
peut on peut réagir si jamais il ya une
trajectoire qui qui sera en direct
relation avec la trajectoire de la terre
c'est ensuite que l'expérience que
prépare la nasa pourrait nous aider à
sauver la planète
elle se déroulera en deux temps d'abord
une sonde approchera dimos un astéroïde
de 800 aides orbiter par une minuscule
une de 120 m elle déploiera des
instruments de mesure et des satellites
de télécommunications puis une deuxième
sonde suivra elle a à peine deux mètres
carrés et va percuter la petite lune à
très grande vitesse
[Musique]
si tout va bien le choc va modifier très
légèrement la trajectoire de didim
hausse mais c'est assez pour éliminer le
risque qu'il pourrait représenter une
autre mission du même genre est déjà en
marche
osiris rex et l'étudié l'astéroïde béni
qui s'approchera dangereusement de la
terre en 2029 des missions semblables
nous permettront également d'en savoir
plus sur le rôle extrêmement important
qu'aurait joué les nombreux astéroïde
qui ont ravagé la terre depuis sa
formation
c'est ce qu'on appelle le grand
bombardement tardif en fait où la terre
a été pulvérisé par cet ensemble de
différents astéroïdes dans lequel
potentiellement il y aurait probablement
des
des traces de vie qui aurait tanner qui
aurait favorisé l'apparition de la vie
sur terre nous ici normand grondin
radio-canada mauvais